[MUSIC PLAYING]
ARPIT MIDHA: Hi, everyone.
I'm Arpit.
I'm the lead PM for Android Go.
PATRIK TORSTENSSON:
And hi, I'm Patrik.
I'm the technical
lead for Android Go.
ARPIT MIDHA: All right.
So I want to start first by
sharing a personal story.
Back in 2010, there was a spike
in farmer suicides in India,
following a really, really
terrible monsoon season.
I was very moved by it.
A bunch of friends
and I got together,
and we started a company
to sell weather insurance
to the farmers of India.
We traveled through states of
Maharashtra and Andhra Pradesh
to meet these farmers,
talk to hundreds of them,
and test our prototypes out.
What I learned was
very astonishing.
It appeared the cool,
innovative products
like rain-indexed weather
insurance already existed,
but very few knew of it.
Very few carried it.
And you know, the vast
majority didn't know about it.
And it wasn't for
the lack of trying
that they didn't know about it.
Hacks existed in the market.
Even the poorest tenant
farmer had a feature phone
that gave him daily text
messages about the commodity
prices that evening.
So what I'm trying to say
is the thirst for knowledge
is alive and kicking, and
yet the access to information
is lacking.
And that access is
only a smartphone away.
But the jump from a
handed-down feature phone
to the smartphone
with internet is
too high for billions
of people out there.
And it is our moral duty
to lower those barriers.
We, at Google, believe that
this access to information
should never be at
the cost of quality.
And that is the reason
we started the project
we internally call Android Go.
Android Go is the next
phase of Google's investment
after Project Svelte, the
original Android One program,
to connect the people who
don't have the access to power
of computing today and
are not connected today.
There are three hurdles
to that access today,
and the first and the
most important of it
is device affordability.
OK, I'm going to take a poll.
How many of you here use a cell
phone that is less than $100?
Raise your hands.
Yeah.
That is true.
So now what I'm
about to say, you'll
understand much better,
which is I personally dogfood
a lot of entry-level devices.
And I can tell you the
experience is very humbling.
So what we're doing for
device affordability is--
the first thing we
need to do is optimize
our OS to run on the lowest
common denominator of SOCs,
memory chipsets,
and screens, memory
as low as 512 megabytes of RAM.
But you all know here--
you're developers--
OS isn't the game, right?
The access to information
comes through apps.
So we're not just
optimizing our OS.
We're also optimizing our
apps, and then sometimes,
writing new ones to
meet the requirements
of the next billion users.
The most important
factor in all of this
is not the apps we build, but
the apps that you all build.
And Patrik and I want to take
this opportunity talk to you
about how can you write your
apps for these next billion
users?
The next biggest
hurdle to information
after device affordability
is data affordability.
So when I talk to people
who aren't connected yet,
they tell me they
want to use data.
They're willing to pay for it.
But they're very afraid.
Data is still very expensive
in large parts of the world.
It's like money to them.
MBs are like the
new social currency.
I kid you not.
There are young people out there
who gift their lovers 100 MB
data packs.
I'm not joking about that.
That's actually true.
It is like currency.
So these users are
willing to come online.
They're willing to pay as long
as they get control over where
their precious MBs are spent.
And that is the reason why we're
building features into our OS
and in our apps that increase
the level of data transparency
as well as can give
them additional controls
to control their data.
The third biggest factor and
hurdle that we want to overcome
is linguistic flexibility.
Now, this is not simply adding
more languages to the OS.
Our users are increasingly
wanting an exposure
to a second language.
People want their
iOS to be in English,
but they want their special
messaging app to be in Spanish.
The same complexity exists
in typing preferences,
in searching preferences, and
in my farmers' case, in browsing
government websites.
So we're building features
into our apps that
accommodate for this
evolution of language
and the preferences of
the next billion users.
So let's jump right in.
Let's let Patrik tell you
how we are solving for device
affordability through
performance, data affordability
through better controls
and transparency,
and how we're solving for
linguistic flexibility
through multilingualism
in our apps.
Thanks.
PATRIK TORSTENSSON:
Thanks, Arpit.
So let's dive into what we're
doing to optimize the phone
experience.
We're improving everything
from the kernel to third party
applications.
So let's start with
the kernel, most
our work in this area
being around the integrated
Android lifecycle
management with Linux.
First we spend time
on tuning the kernel
to be more optimized for
the entry-level devices.
This seems like a
simple task, but it
involves a lot of
nitty gritty details
like tuning cache sizes,
tuning swapping, tuning
all kind of
threading parameters,
as Linux, for a
long time, has been
optimized for the server side.
Even though Android has
done a lot of changes,
there's still a lot to do there.
Then we implemented prioritized
reclaiming of memory.
I'll go into more
details about that
soon as it's a key part
of what we've done.
And we've done better
integration of memory events
from Linux, allowing
us to be much more
proactive with cleaning
up apps in the background
and making sure we have
more memory available.
So Android Go use
Linux control groups
that enables better
resource management.
Cgroups, as called in Linux,
isolate each application
and allows Android to
prioritize memory collection
and swapping for
each application.
We have then integrated
that with Android's activity
management.
And that allows us to be much
more aggressive in swapping
away memory for low
priority processes
and better in selecting
which processes to stop.
Overall, this results
in more memory
being available for important
applications, hence yours,
and leading to a smoother
user experience even on a 512
megabyte to one gig device.
To reduce the number
of memory pages
Androids are using, we've
optimized how DEX files are
laid out in memory,
as they currently
tend to consume quite
a lot of clean pages,
leading to more swapping
on entry-level devices.
We're using profiling
to redo the DEX layout
and co-locate them.
As you can see in
this picture, we're
taking code pages that are
used and then bundling them
together.
And therefore, we're also
creating more clean space
for the kernel to collect.
This improves both startup
time and memory usage.
It's also allowing,
then, the kernel
to be much more aggressive
of collecting code pages
that is not used
on that platform.
So we are doing innovations
in the UI design.
Let's talk about
recents as an example.
95% of the time,
our entry-level user
only switch between their
four recent applications.
So we redesigned the UI
to enable faster switching
and save memory by reducing
memory intensive bitmaps.
This is just one example
of optimizations in the UI
that we're doing
to make it smoother
but also to fit the form
factor, as it's very different,
and, of course, like
you will hear many times
during my talks, save memory.
So we are rearchitecturing
Google Play Services.
We're splitting the API
services into dynamic modules.
This reduces disk
footprint, which
is also a critical thing on
these devices, but also--
take a guess-- reducing
the memory footprint.
This is very important
as there are still
a lot of APIs in Google
Play Services not used
on entry-level devices
in these markets.
And, of course, we're working
on making applications
to take less space, less memory,
and consume less network.
We designed some brand new
Google apps like YouTube Go,
but we're also
optimizing our existing
apps like Chrome and Play and a
lot of the pre-installed apps.
These new Google
apps aim to take
less than 10 meg of
APK size, and I'll
talk more why 10 meg later on.
Our OEM and carrier partners
are also joining us,
and we'll be creating
optimized versions specifically
for the entry-level
devices to make sure
that we keep the promise
of the quality we want
to deliver for this platform.
ARPIT MIDHA: All right.
So I'll talk about how we're
solving for data affordability.
I talked to you
about how important
it is for this set of users
to have better controls
and transparency about their
data, told you that is the key.
So today, users have to type
in a really complicated code--
*#125-- some number, followed
by another complicated set
of characters-- to find
out their data balance.
We want to make this
super, super easy.
We want to make this directly
accessible with a downswipe
from your Quick Settings.
Now to do that,
we're creating an API
where third party
developers or carriers could
provide this information to
the users by each data pack.
So for their 4G data
pack, their 3G data pack,
their social media data back,
and so on, all those balances
would be available to the user
right at their fingertips.
Now the next thing,
once they come online,
we want them to
stay online, right?
So imagine it's your
regular Sunday afternoon.
You're on your little messaging
thread with your family,
a heated political
debate comes up,
your uncle just says the
most provocative thing ever,
and you have a witty comeback.
But bam-- your data runs out.
You don't want that to happen.
It's happened to me.
You really don't
want that to happen.
But jokes apart, our users
actually travel for kilometers
to recharge their phones
or top up their phones.
And oftentimes, when
they reach that far,
they still don't know,
and even the seller
doesn't know, what the latest
promotion by the carrier is.
So what we want to do is
create an API for the carriers
to provide this latest
information to the users
and enable you to
top up your data
plans right there on the phone.
So that's how we
plan to do that.
The next, these users
see apps using data
in the background as a
hole in their wallet.
They hate it.
They hate it so much
that they will either
turn off the data altogether
in the phone, which
harms the whole
point of this, which
is to get them data information,
or they delete your apps.
They just absolutely
delete your apps,
which is horrible because you
worked so hard to make them.
So what we want to do is give
them controls so that they
can choose which
apps get their MBs
or which apps choose it when.
So that's how the
OS is working hard
to make sure that there's
transparency and controls.
But our apps also pitch in.
Let's talk about Chrome.
Chrome has already
launched this feature out.
And today, it is already saving
750 terabytes of data a day
for the early adopters.
On Chrome, data
in Android Chrome,
Chrome's Data Saver features
will be turned on for default
so they don't have to opt in.
And what it does, it
transcodes data on its servers
before it reaches you.
Therefore, that's
how we save you data.
Second, it also detects when
you are on a lowest connection,
and then gives you
previews of pages,
that way helping
you load the page
and get the information faster.
That just Chrome.
I want to talk about my
favorite one of this.
YouTube Go is an app that
we had to build from scratch
to meet the hard requirements
that we put on ourselves.
Once you start putting in the
requirements of the lowest end
SSEs and memory and the needs
of the next billion users,
we had to build
this from scratch.
Now, how many of you look for
music videos on YouTube Go?
All of you, right?
So isn't it frustrating when
you want to download and look
at the latest Adele
song, and it turns out
to be another fan's
karaoke video?
Yeah, right?
So imagine that
frustration, even
with people who have
little data balance.
That's really, really
disappointing for them.
So we built the preview
feature so that people preview
what they're about
to watch before they
spend their precious
few MBs doing that.
And again, in this
next billion users,
you can't assume the similar
or constant data rates
throughout the day.
You can't assume the same
level of connectivity.
So we want to give users,
again, additional control
to choose the quality of the
video they want to watch.
Next, some of the
users might have
a free Wi-Fi in their office.
So we want them to
have the ability
to download these videos and
watch them on their bus ride
back.
And the best of all--
I don't know about you, but
when I see a funny video,
I have to share it, right?
But I don't want these
next billion users--
or we don't want this
to have them pay for that
video and have their friends
pay for it, too.
So we're building offline
peer-to-peer sharing
of videos within YouTube
so that you don't
have to pay for cellular data.
So that's how we're
saving for data.
Now let's talk about solving
for linguistic flexibility.
When you want to express
your thoughts and your ideas,
Google Keyboard will
come to your rescue.
And this time I'm not
going to talk over it.
I'm just going to show you, and
we'll have some fun doing it.
Patrik, I'll need your help.
All right, if we can
switch to my cell phone?
All right.
So Patrik is here.
And I grew up in India,
so I speak Hindi.
So I want to switch over to
typing phonetically in Hindi,
but I want to write
to him in Hindi.
So let's say
[SPEAKING HINDI] which
means, "How are you, friend?"
And I'm typing in English
letters phonetically,
it's going to him, and it's
typing out in Hindi script,
and it goes to him.
But it so turns out
that he is Swedish.
He doesn't get my Hindi, right?
So that sucks.
So what can I do?
So again, Google
Keyboard to the rescue.
I'll switch to translations.
Now I'm going to type in English
letters in my native script,
and still send it to him.
So let's try this again.
[SPEAKING HINDI] It
translates to Swedish for me,
and there you go.
So if that doesn't get
the geek out of you,
then nothing else will.
[APPLAUSE]
So that was Google
Keyboard, right?
So this is how you can
express yourself better.
And beyond that, Google Keyboard
has 191 languages supported,
22 Indian languages supported.
So this is all good.
But what if you want to
consume information, right?
And at that point, Chrome comes.
So Chrome will
automatically detect--
or Chrome, it already detects--
what your OS's language is.
And any time you
access information
on a page that is different
from your phone's language,
it gives you proactive
suggestions to translate it.
And here's an example of that.
So that'll help you
consume information.
It'll help that
farmer I talked about
consume the information
in the language that's
most comfortable to him.
So that's all the translations.
But you may ask,
why does it matter?
Why should you care?
PATRIK TORSTENSSON: So
let's dig into that.
So one third of the
global shipments in 2017
will be sub-hundred
dollar devices.
This is a must
segment for developers
that are focusing on
the growing user base
or focused on the mass market.
So you may be
thinking this is, you
know, [INAUDIBLE]
market problem,
but it turns out
that's not true.
This is not [INAUDIBLE]
market product.
US is the second largest market
for sub-hundred dollar devices,
as it's a huge prepaid market.
Therefore, we're announcing,
starting with OMR 1,
all devices shipping
with one gig or less RAM
will get Android
Go configuration.
And going forward,
other releases
will have a Go configuration.
So this is a sustained
effort that we'll
continue developing over time.
So optimized Google
apps is a good start.
But it's your apps
that will really
solve the needs of the
next billion users.
So let's see some hands.
How many in here are optimizing
for entry-level devices today?
Yeah, that's quite few.
How many in here think they need
to optimize for low-end devices
going forward?
That's a lot more.
That's very positive.
I hope I see more hands next
year during the first question.
And to be honest, several of
you have already jumped in,
like Skype and Limelight.
And I hope that many more
of you, after this talk,
will start thinking seriously
about these devices,
either develop new apps or
optimizing your existing apps.
So we at Android Go, we have
added [? target ?] [? to ?]
[? game ?] to the Play Store
to help such apps get better
distribution.
And we'll continue
surfacing these apps
in more ways in the Play
Store for entry-level devices.
We will also optimize the
Play Store to save more data,
as data is very
important in this market.
So we'll be supporting
secure peer-to-peer transfer
and installation of apps.
And we'll also support delaying
your download of the apps
to a point when you may have a
better data plan because it's
quite common in these
countries that you have
much cheaper data
during night when
it's less congestion
on the networks.
So that's a feature.
You will be able to say, hey,
download this automatically
when I have a
lower-cost data plan.
And the app will take care of
understanding when in time that
is.
So all of this is
what we are doing.
And it's an continuing,
ongoing effort as we speak.
Let's dive into what you should
be doing as app developers.
First, let's talk about
data connectivity.
3G and LTE is growing
around the world,
and we're very happy for that.
And 80% of the smartphone growth
is in the emerging markets.
But 2G will still be over
a billion devices in 2020.
So therefore, it's
important to design
apps that can handle slow
and flaky connectivity.
And it's important to create a
useful experience for the users
without or on bad networks.
And don't forget to adjust when
that changes, because networks
in these countries is quite
flaky and comes and goes,
so you may have a very fast
4G, then you end up on Wi-Fi,
then you have no connectivity.
So think about
optimizing for this
and use the APIs that exist in
the platform to detect this.
One way to improve this
handling, as shown here,
is to prioritize text
over heavy images,
so show something relevant
to the user while you can,
because you don't know if the
connectivity will disappear
or become bad or worse.
So low-end devices
will continue to be
memory restricted for quite
some time going forward.
So be efficient of
how you use memory,
have short-lived services,
eliminate unused--
unneeded wakeups, use
Firebase job dispatcher
to handle network tasks.
It's both network
and battery aware.
You can set policies
around saying, hey,
I only want to do this task if
it's on a unmetered network.
Have this same retry
policy so that you
don't consume a lot
of power and battery
without gaining
anything for the users.
Use activity manager is low
RAM to adjust the experience
and memory usage of
your application,
as that will be
one of the ways we
will signal you're on
the Android Go platform.
And that includes
optimizing your images,
as they can be quite big.
And these devices are
normally small displays, not
a high resolution,
not the best screen.
So there is no need
to save the images
in super high resolution.
But also, size your
caches correctly.
Think about how much you're
caching, and anything else
that may take memory.
There'll be a constant
trade off on these devices.
So think through what
kind of experience
you are trying to
give your users.
And also, test.
There is a lot of
tools out there
that allows you to simulate
being on a 2G connection.
It's quite revealing to do.
At Google, we have
Wi-Fi networks that
simulate a poor 2G connection.
And its a horrible
experience today.
So I recommend doing that.
So this is an example of
using Android Studio Memory
Monitor to measure the memory
usage between two apps.
The app is using
its low RAM flag
to detect if you are on
the Android Go device.
It automatically adjusts
some image sizes and caches
internally.
And therefore, it's quite
easy to see the memory
difference between them.
The reason I have this here is
to remind everyone in this room
that Android Studio profiling
tools are very powerful.
There's been a lot of
talks about them this week.
And I strongly recommend
you to check them
out and use the
tooling that we provide
to help optimize your app.
We have tooling
around the ability
to look into your
network traffic.
You can see the distribution
of network, CPU profiling,
and memory profiling.
So get on top of
your app and see
where are you consuming memory?
Our research tells us that users
see a app greater than 10 meg
as too heavy.
And that means the
user has a tendency
to go and delete that app if
they're running low on space.
So 10 meg is kind of
the breaking point
where they think it's acceptable
for app size in these markets.
Image and language resources
are the biggest offenders
we've seen in apps.
And therefore,
optimize your images,
think about what you're
trying to deliver, and be
smart about translations.
There's been quite
a lot of talks,
again, this week, about this.
I'll refer to some
of them later.
Remove code that
you're not using.
It's a simple task,
but important.
We are optimizing the kernel
to be much better of collecting
these code pages.
But it's much easier if
you haven't allocated them
from the start.
And don't forget to optimize
for the smaller screens.
That's something we spend
quite a lot of time on.
And I strongly recommend
you do the same.
And you may want to use
multi-APK to get better
targeting around this, so
you can target these devices
specifically.
And one of the talks
I strongly recommend
is Engineering for High
Performance With Tools.
That was held this morning
if I remember correctly.
So we have implemented a lot of
new functionality in Android Go
to help improve memory and
battery like background check,
that improves the system's
ability to control and manage
background It sets the same
limit of how often you can pull
Wi-Fi and location, depending
on the conditions you're in.
And therefore, for
Android Go, we strongly
recommend you to target
Android Go API level 26.
I know this is very hard
for existing applications,
but it'll give the user
quite a lot of benefits
on this platform if you do.
So important to say is that the
changes I've been talking about
is really good even for
existing apps today.
There is a lot of low-entry
devices out there in the market
as we speak.
And the experience of
them is quite poor as-is.
So this is something you really
should be thinking about today.
And the market is just growing.
And having said
that, we're planning
to preview Android Go
the end of this year,
and with the first
devices shipping
the first half of 2018.
And you should start now
and be ready for Android Go.
And that's it.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]